right okay good evening let's make a
start don't worry i'll just pour it it's
okay take time
right good evening and welcome everybody
my name is danny kendall i'll be uh
chairing tonight's meeting of the
planning committee for stratfor district
council um before we get started maybe
just a couple of bits of housekeeping if
that's all right um if i could remind
members of the public to turn off their
mobile phones or certainly switch them
to silent that'll be excellent i could
do that now checking mine's all sorted
um next bit of housekeeping just let
people know of course tonight's meeting
is being recorded and webcast live
should you wish to watch it back again
at your leisure in the next few days
it'll be available on the council
website if you've got nothing else to do
that is um beyond that i think uh i can
just talk you through a little bit
obviously we're still going through the
covert palaver at the moment so speakers
who are registered to speak tonight um
if you when you come up um you can
sanitize your hands the sanitizer
provided at the front here and once
you've finished speaking if you'd use
one of the wet wipes to wipe down the
microphone and the table area that'd be
fantastic as well thank you very much
for that
right let's go through just a few
introductions if that's okay uh our
planning officers who will be presenting
applications this evening are paul
thompson and victoria kempton over here
we have our planning manager here
richard gunn i'll come back to you in a
second richard uh
committee services is being treated is
being operated virtually tonight by
olivia quinn and legal services is mason
nash on my left richard did you have a
statement you'd like to make at this
point
thanks mr chairman yeah my role as
planning manager tonight is to provide
impartial planning advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you
thank you richard excellent um right
where do we go to now apologies for
absence mesa have you got those for me
yeshua apologies received from
councillors adam crump foreman and
richards splendid thank you very much
right then we moved to item two which is
decla disclosure of interests from the
committee i'll kick off one of the
speakers uh tonight is known to me
because i teach his son at school in my
other job um i don't think that'll
impact my ability to share tonight's
meeting if that's all right any other
disclosures of interest country seraphim
thank you item seven councilor mills
thanks mr chairman um
item five on the agenda that's um
home holdings lane um
application number 21 stroke zero one
nine five three stroke if you will i'm
known to the applicants i'll sit
i'll sit away from the desk that's great
thank you council mills any other
disclosures counselor adam
thank you chair that's per council ahead
to seraphin just to disclose an
interesting as much as i'm the
neighbouring ward member but i'm
entering into this with an open mind
excellent thank you council adam there
are no further disclosures of interest
in that case
um we moved to our first item now the
first item type is item three um which
has been withdrawn from tonight
tonight's committee so there's nothing
further for us to do with that so we'll
skip that one
uh we then moved to item four which is
uh which have has been well
a number of the reasons for it coming to
the committee were the objections from
the board member and the parish council
both of those objections have now been
withdrawn you'll see also we have no
speakers on that item tonight our usual
practice when that's the case is for us
to delegate this particular application
to officers um i'm happy to propose that
do i have a seconder councillor jennings
just beat you two at council mills all
those in favor of delegating item four
please show
that's great therefore the committee has
resolved to delegate uh application
reference twenty one slash zero one nine
one one three slash vary and we move
then to our first proper application for
the evening which is item five
this then is
application reference twenty one slash
zero one nine five three slash f u l
it's home holdings uh lower taiso
um the description is for the opening
opening over gragon farm gateway to form
a proposed access road presenting
officer
paul thompson
thank you chair good evening members
ladies and gentlemen in the gallery and
online uh
you should
now be able to see that
on the screen we are in uh lower taiso
at the the northern extent of the the
village
on lane end this is the application site
outlined in red
home holdings
uh
the
red building there is listed
and the green dash lines are public
bytes away
the proposal is to add a second access
to this development of two dwellings
which has been part implemented been
trenches dug
there have been a number of applications
on the site
and uh
this is the final
form with one dwelling perpendicular to
the other and that second dwelling plot
two will be served by the new access
here
that's what it looked like in march this
year uh as you can see there's a remains
of a five bar gate there and the gate
post but it is very overgrown and at
some point since it was last used
presumably there's been a ditch
dug along this side of the road
that is the view out of the village
towards the 50 mile per hour limit up
towards the main road
and that is view in the other direction
towards the bend back in towards
taiso proper
my recommendation is to grant planning
permission chair
thank you paul okay we'll move to our
first speaker on this application that's
certain councilor malcolm littlewood
taiso parish council councillor
welcome council so i'm sure you know the
routine by now you've been here a couple
of times before if you press the button
in the middle that should start your mic
you'll have three minutes to speak if
you'd remain seated at the end for any
questions the committee may have of you
in that case over to you sir
uh good evening councillors um
yes the the parish council uh is
supportive of the development of the two
dwellings there's no argument about that
but uh has objected to the opening of
new entrants on the grounds that it's
too close to the fifth now speed limit
a second roadway uh
development
uh up to the new
uh to the new two new properties uh is
uh unnecessary as the existing roadway
as was in the previous scheme um
quite competently addresses that issue
also
opening up the entrance that's been
described by
the planning officer
would require the destruction of mature
trees and a thick mixed native hedgerow
um
i
think i know could you go back to the
block plan please again
possum
never mind leave it on that one that's
fine okay um so um the uh entrance uh is
is
a hedge width away from an existing farm
entrance which is well used uh although
not metalled it's a grassed flat area
which has got a culverted entrance to it
this
particular
new scheme
does not
show any historical evidence of having
an access onto the road there is indeed
a gate post there um and uh obviously it
was clearer in march than it is today
but because of the the the uh uh growth
of the the hedgerows but there is no
culvert and they uh
at all
as one of those photographs uh showed
and the proximity to the 15 mile an hour
speed limit is is something like six
meters
uh and that is
just the other side of the farm entrance
so on that basis and i'm
truncating this for these previously
approved scheme using one entrance only
sufficient for the egress and access to
the three properties which would reduce
hard surface area and flood risk and we
reference
cs core
saturday 2.3 cutting the entrance would
require the destruction of mature mixed
native hedgerow and the filling of
mature trees reducing valuable natural
habitat uh cs7 and possibly cs6
the proposed entrance is
close to the 50 mile an hour speed limit
within a few meters of the existing farm
entrance
thank you very much excellent do we have
any questions for the parish council
councillor dixon
do you have a photograph at all of the
mature trees which are at risk only i
didn't notice them on those cliffs if i
could ask the planning officer to
show the image with the vehicle in
profile please
there no i think there's another one
with the profile of the vehicle
there if you can see that the um the
tree in the right hand foreground is
marks the edge
of
the proposed opening which would have to
uh be uh
failed to enable a splay to be created
there are other trees in there uh naked
trees and it's a mixed hedge as you can
see
where the vehicle is parked to the left
the right hand side near side of the
vehicle would mark the opening
to the new opening to be made
it would be if it were perpendicular to
that position yes
okay any further questions please
no
in that case thank you very much for
your time if you just give the table a
wipe down for me thank you very much
right we should move then strictly
speaking i think to um the
applicant's agent uh steve taylor is he
in the room yet
mr taylor anyone
in that case i think the best we can do
um the meeting was well advertised as
starting at six o'clock so the best we
can do is if uh council fielding doesn't
mind coming forward as the ward member
will go to you first and then if mr
taylor arrives in time we will skip back
to him
welcome council feeling well you know
the routine don't you so you have five
minutes i think i've been around the box
okay over to you though um councillors
chairman
uh officers
um although there is a sign of the old
gateway
the the it's only the hanging post
that's
in position there there is no clapping
first so
it's probably
long gone the
there is no indication of a culvert or a
bridge over the ditch
which to my mind indicates that there is
no or has not been
um a gateway there uh there has been
and
one of the
um
ex-fellow district councillors has lived
there for 35 years
and she's never seen a ditch there
i mean a bridge there sorry
um the ditch is very important because
with the flooding that we've been having
over the course of since about i think
the last numbers in 98
um the water was virtually up to
the front door of the houses along the
bottom bottom there which you can see
where the cars parked
so that with another culvert going in
there we're going to cause yet another
blockade or
prospective blockage um paul could you
put the google earth one on please
no not that
one that has an overview
and if you can zoom in a bit
right um
you can just about see it can you bring
it
go north a bit no the other way sorry
right just on the corner there um
they've had to put in special drainage
in the in their culvert
they've also had a gritting lorry
disappearing into that ditch
i think it was probably icy weather just
a little bit further along the hedge
there is a footpath that goes up
to up into the fields behind
and
next to that footpath is another
entrance into
the
lower um holdings
so
he's wanting to put in
yet a third
opening
into his property because he's going to
maintain the one that was agreed granted
when we are granted the planning
permission for the two houses
that one circles round to the back of
his house he now wants to put in yet
another one that is going to go right
the way around the back of the houses
i think it's totally unnecessary we've
got a perfectly good hedge there the
district council is very keen on
protecting green issues and biomass oh
sorry not biomass and biodiversity with
regards to bugs bees and anything else
that travels through hedges
um and i just don't see why we need to
cut down yet another hedge
uh we've got prairie land all round
in the district and it's nice to see
that the hedges are being maintained
the
ditch the other side of the hedge to the
north side is runs right the way through
to the
stream in oxhil so it is an important
um
watercourse and when i was looking at it
two days ago there was water coming
through from the other side of the road
whether it is coming out of
the um aonb which
is behind taiso or whether it is a
stream somewhere there are lots of
streams coming out of the bank
it of the aonb so really we've got a
problem with water we've got a problem
with removing the hedge there is
absolutely no need to put in yet another
entrance onto the site
i rest my case
thank you councillor fielding with 40
seconds to go as well excellent time i
can do my best lovely right okay any
questions to the board member please
councillor
fleming um
yes sort of what provision
over for a culvert has the uh the
applicant made is he has he given any
any method of construction of how he's
going to do this culvert or not there's
absolutely no design that i've seen on
the
planning portal whether the planning
officer has seen one i don't know but
there is no indication of how it's going
to be built perhaps we come back to that
as a point of clarification then yeah
okay
any other questions to the ward member
none in that case councillor fielding
thank you very much i notice our next
speaker uh councillor taylor oh sorry
counts the feeling would you just wipe
down the table for me please thank you
covered flummery thank you uh
mr taylor i've spotted you just come in
that i said we did skip you gave you a
few extra second scare you're the next
speak if you'd like to come up you can
sit on the table on the right hand side
down on your left
thank you
that's great thanks council building
welcome
okay so he made it um right taylor um
you have three minutes i think you know
the routine you've been here before as
well yes you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end over to you okay
thanks
right um
start with the general permitted
development order planning permission is
actually not required to alter an
existing gateway adjacent to the highway
subject to three conditions none of
which apply in this case
but
nevertheless the applicant has applied
in order that the application is seen to
be complying with higher regulations in
terms of visibility displays and
construction standards
the existing access which you've seen on
the overhead which is closer to the bend
and i have to say at this point that the
only reason this is before the committee
is because
the parish council have raised questions
of safety of the bend
the existing access again closer to the
bend has been considered on four
separate occasions by four different
highway engineers
it has also been considered by two
planning inspectors
for the site and in none of these
instances was proximity the bend
considered to adversely affect
the access
the proposed access which is opening up
an existing gateway
is actually further from the bend than
the one that's been approved
it has adequate visibility in both
directions fully complies with highway
standards
and in addition
the applicant has provided during the
course of the application a report by
gerald ford
chartered engineer member of the
institute of highway engineers and he
concluded that the existing bend has a
positive benefit in that it slows down
traffic and effectively acts as a
traffic calming measure for all the
various accesses and driveways to the
properties in the vicinity
in short
there is no reason in my opinion and the
parish have provided no evidence to the
contrary to
go against the officer's recommendation
in this case nor that of the highway
engineer nor all the previous highway
engineers that have looked at this site
um
and we should go with the officer's
recommendation and adopted policy
thank you
thank you mr taylor any questions from
the committee
yes council curtis
thank you thank you chair um
i think you said existing gateway three
times yep um can you ask can you tell us
when the existing gateway was last used
uh i can't but it's been in place for
probably 35 years
there's a photograph of it on the
submitted plan
thank you
yes councilor henshaw seraphin
there's a sparse bit of hedgerow which
is sparse where the gateway is currently
situated
it it'll be built to highway standards
so there will more than likely be a one
meter wide cut
plastic pipe in the culvert tarmacked
over the top
okay there have been no further
questions mr taylor thank you very much
thank you
okay well we've had our ward member
we've had all our speakers uh points of
clarification council dixon
thank you chairman
paul uh the report indicates that uh it
will be necessary to remove some
hedgerow
we've obviously heard from the parish
council that they suspect that the
visibility displays will require a
mature tree to be removed
can you give an opinion on the parish
council's comments please
um well that would be a matter we would
look at in the landscape scheme which
was conditioned um
obviously we'd
prefer not to lose that tree
and if we can
rejig the
access to to make that work then that's
certainly the aim
i'll go again with my cover construction
uh has anything been submitted to uh
to a
design or whatever of how they're gonna
construct the
the culvert that's gonna run in a ditch
not at this stage but again that would
be a matter for the the landscape's
gonna be soft and hard landscaping um
and again the as well as that condition
there is also the highways condition
which stipulates that it can't reduce
the effective capacity of the cool but
the or the ditch as it exists
so just to clarify on that it's likely
to be as the uh agent just said a
a plastic pipe that runs under the road
if that's what he's going to submit then
okay and we'll obviously consult
highways on that and make sure that
that's acceptable thank you any other
points of clarification
yes council jennings
just get uh just so clear on this is it
uh
is the end proposed entrance in the 30
mile an hour or 40 miles um
does receive the sign where it says 50.
i presume
this is a 30.
uh yeah
and
also just to clarify and confirm the
highways are okay with this
they are council yes thank you very much
okay
we've had our points of clarification
should we go to the debate
who would like to start
anyone
i'll go council jennings and councillor
dixon
i mean on this one i fully understand uh
the
the parish's feelings and the ward
members feelings on
on the the loss of a bit of hedge
hedgerow
but uh
already where it's all about safety and
as far as i'm concerned uh
highways
uh given giving the green light on this
as far as cold bits
is concerned that'll be part of building
regs
um there's no
evidence-based data to show that this is
dangerous
i'm quite happy to go with the office's
uh
decision on this one that i won't
propose it yet unless everyone had their
say thank you councillor jennings
councillor dixon
thank you chairman uh i think uh matt
and i are on the the same wavelengths
essentially and uh i don't see an any
planning reason to actually refuse this
one to be honest um so i will propose
that we go with the officer's
recommendation of grant
wonderful thank you very much we've got
a proposal there then councillor curtis
thank you um
i'm afraid i disagree um
the existing entrance
seems quite adequate for the purposes
um i think we should be trying to
maintain existing hedgerows wherever
possible i'm certainly very uneasy about
the tree being chopped down i'm not
convinced that
the safety of that so i'm afraid i i
wouldn't support this
anyone else want to speak at this point
council jennings
in that case um i'd like to
second the
recommendation and uh and also mention
about the tree that i say this tree
could be
uh saved by the landscaping conditions
so that to me isn't an issue so again on
that with that in mind i'm happy to
second recommendation thank you council
jennings i've got to say i i agree with
you from my perspective as well i
sympathize with the parish council this
is one of those where you know as as a
member of parish council you often you
know you feel you know an area really
really well
and it's sometimes you know it's one of
those heart versus head decisions but
from a planning committee perspective
i'm not seeing enough material grounds
to go against the officer's
recommendation especially when you take
into consideration the
highways consultation if the highways
officer and highway department are happy
with this
it's a difficult one for me to go
against them they are the experts so i'm
i'm going to go with the office's
recommendation as well
um any other speakers on it
in that case we'll go to the vote then
um with those please in favor of
granting the application please show
those against
okay one one and uh abstentioned
okay abstention that's excellent thank
you in that case brilliant the committee
therefore resolves to grant application
reference twenty one zero one nine five
three slash f u l
we move to our next application which is
item six on tonight's agenda
uh it's found on page 27 and is
application reference 21 slash
01518 slash ful
uh site address is 40 george street uh
for flat roof dormer extension etc i'm
going to leave this to presenting
officer paul thompson if that's okay
cool you're ready and i want to rush you
thanks again
out over to you
i'll uh plunge in with both feet uh yeah
this is the uh resubmission of a scheme
in stockton uh that the committee
refused earlier on this year
uh
we are on george street it's an existing
pair of maisonettes four dwellings on
the site as it stands the proposal that
we refused
is not that one it's that one
um
so a box stormer on the rear reef lights
on the front
and this is
the current scheme that we're looking at
tonight a reduction in the number of
roof lights same box stormer at the rear
the other change is the parking
arrangement at the front the parking
arrangement will now provide 11 spaces
which is sufficient for
the existing dwellings as well as the
new dwellings that are proposed
um
that's two new dwellings in the roof
space i should say
um that's what it currently looks like
so imagine that with some pre-flights
this is side view
and this is
the rear where most of the change will
be apparent
um
i should add that the
proposed
parking area will be grass creek and
my recommendation there for is to grant
commission thank you chair
excellent caught me out there thank you
okay all right so we go to our first
speaker please uh bill robinson
stockton parish council
hello councillor welcome
please take a seat if you would sanitize
as you sit down that'd be fantastic
thank you very much
i think you've been here before you know
the routine as well
you have three minutes uh if you remain
seated for any questions at the end
uh whenever you're ready over to you
all right
thank you chair
good evening committee
the stockton parish council
opposed this development
because it's essentially the same
as the one that the planning committee
refused
on the 23rd of the third 21st nothing
much has changed
if we look at
your own document the
course strategy page
194 countryside and villages it states
all other types of development in the
countryside will need to be fully
justified and offer significant benefits
to the local area
this does neither
at on the same page it also says in
6.12.4
the development address must address
local needs this is your own district
council policy and it is to have a
bearing
on the development this development
addresses no
housing need of any kind that anyone has
ever seen
the car parking the photograph you've
shown was slightly disingenuous simply
because it shows lots of spaces if you
go there after five o'clock at any night
or at the weekend it is around full
as is george street round full
so there will be much more traffic which
is
against your policy as well
the impact
on neighbours
there it's going to overlook the back
which is the rear at the top end of a
new development
nelson's way
it can do nothing else but overlook it
because the way it's built
the impact on the street scene is
totally at odds with this development
in the street itself there are 74
dwellings
granted that eight of them are single
story but there's no roof window roof
lights at all
no
this cannot do anything but be of a
detriment to the street sea
and if we look at the overall
developments within stockton i know that
the
numbers in the
course strategy are
said to be a minima
but
it is
indicated that there should be no more
than 12
currently stockton is somewhere between
14 and 15
and this will not do anyhow help to
excuse me to anyone thank you mr chair
thank you very much uh do we have any
questions for the parish council from
our committee
that's the henshaw seraphin
yep
23rd of the third
it was
refused on crimes of parking
impact on neighbours they packed on the
streets
as far as we could see and as far as i'm
this parish council is concerned nothing
much has changed this is just the same
application
being served up in a slightly different
way
council mills
uh hello good good evening the would you
say that the extra car parking is um has
been added to this application though
that has isn't it it's not on its own no
uh the extra car parking we don't see as
being terribly helpful simply because
the way it will have to go in and out
we think that the likelihood is that
there's going to be have to be car
parking on the street and if you take a
look at the car parking up george street
you will see it is round
chocolate
thank you very much thank you
i'm not seeing any further questions so
in that case thank you very much for
your time tonight thank you very much mr
chair thank you
if i could ask you just to wipe down the
table using one of the little wet wipes
for me is that all right thank you
okay committee uh we have no further
speakers we have no ward member here
tonight so should we go to points of
clarification any questions for our
officer
uh council mills thank councillor
jennings uh paul and we did come back
onto the car parking at how much added
car parking space is there for this
application
please
well there's uh
six spaces on site currently which isn't
enough for the four two bed dwellings
that are already on site
the scheme that we've got here would
provide 11 spaces which covers those
dwellings the two new dwellings and the
visitor space
so it's a net benefit a net improvement
rather
council jennings
uh highways
um highways
what what are they kind of what are they
saying at the moment man
uh initially objected the the initial
scheme was fairly similar to the the
previous scheme um in that it had tandem
bays and the
other things that the committee
found uh inappropriate last time um we
worked with the applicant to
hash out this approach
highways were happy with it they wanted
the drop curb minimising basically so
now you've got a single point of entry
onto the site you've got a maneuvering
area within the site and so you can exit
exit and enter the site in a forward
gear and
sufficient spaces of sufficient size to
meet the
heart oh of the spd standards
um i think i cover this in my report but
um it's basically
where there would be overlooking of
private space it would be a distance
that exceeds our standards
um anything under that distance is
either a blank wall or public space
council dixon
thank you chairman paul have we got a
plan
showing the allocation of the parking i
don't not actually
as it were lined plots but you've gone
through those slides at a fast pace so
i'd like to be able to
see if there is it is probably zooming
onto that one
um because i just want to know where
they are doing the parking
can i ask maybe paul could you have a
show the previous application then we
can compare them with that helpful that
would that would help
i appreciate the talking about grass
creek and therefore it might look like
grasses too maybe just walking past
provided it's maintained and it's not
just dandelions
two three four
okay sorry bear with me i'm just having
to
go
back to e planning for this
uh
okay
hmm
all right go there in the end so uh on
the right there is um the
sort of the final version
um
that was in the refused scheme last time
the one on the right
is the one that we're looking at tonight
no counselor that's the the one we
accused yes
existing
that was the previous application that
was refused
right
thank you
thank you chair um i was also going to
ask for a bit of a zoom in so you've
done that well done thank you um
would you also be able to perform some
more computer trickery by flicking
between the existing and new you did
that really well before just so i can
get a kind of uh feel for the
change i i should have put this in my
presentation
that was refused
i meant the elevation of the
house plans the yeah you did it before
that part's a lot easier
that's the refused scheme
that's the current scheme
i should add it's not actually going to
get smaller
thank you and thank you for your
computer skills cheers
counselor curtis that you indicated
thank you and
paul can you i we've probably seen it
but just a couple of things um
can you tell me or tell us how many
parking spaces there were in the
previously refused application
uh 10 if memory serves and my counting
will say that so the one that was
refused is was 10
and this one is
11. it's this so just just to say that's
that
in
it basically adds a visitor space which
which is the requirement necessary
um and also
makes it so that you don't have to
reverse out into the road you've got a
massive drop curve neither of which i
always was totally happy with and just
one other point if i made sure um
the climate change and sustainable
construction
subject conditions securing water
recycling bins and an electric vehicle
charging point um did you mean
a single or would we be looking at
a number of charging points
for the wording of the condition i'd
have to um just double check
part of the spd and there will be a
minimum standard for the dwellings the
only
um point there would be that we
can't theoretically force them to
provide evcps for the existing dwellings
because they're already there we can't
make them fix a problem already exists
we can suggest it gently in the notes
thank you
okay
right any other points of clarification
we're all happy
right should we go to the debate then
who would like to kick us off councillor
mills
thanks mr chairman
yeah uh it's quite right with the
project council um chairman said it
rammed along there
more than rammed i've never seen
anything like it
um and i can't see
myself how this differs
an awful lot and we we
refused it before on street scene as
well
um
i'm not sure about increasing
a hell of a hell of a lot of car parking
space but
to me there's not a lot of difference
from the previous applications chairman
so i can't say i'm happy with it at the
moment thank you
thank you council mills anyone else in
the debate
council
jennings
at the moment to me and obviously there
are a lot less lights in this
new building there's more car parking
um
the officer seems to have had a lot of
contact with the applicant
a lot of work's been done on this
um
as far as the road is concerned as
always i'll go back to the highways they
seem to be happy with it
um
the new
the building will incorporate a lot of
new modern
building methods which will help
green issues
i'm leaning towards the
office's
recommendations at the moment
thank you got cancer dixons then eden
thank you chairman
uh i too i'm leaning towards the
officer's recommendation
uh i think the
change
in
being able to drive out in forward gear
is a distinct improvement on the road
aspects to this so we've gained a
parking space
obviously even the one that we
application we refused last time created
more parking spaces and are currently
there so the fact that we now
or this application proposes the number
of spaces which meets the spd
and we actually gain
more off street parking should help the
general complex of of george street i
appreciate i don't know the area um but
you know every little helps i would sing
in that regard um so essentially i would
propose that
we
grant in accordance with the officer's
recommendation thank you council dixon
council adam
thank you chair um
yeah i'm kind of more or less aligned
with councillors jennings and dixon in
terms of i do think it has changed i
think the street scene itself will
probably benefit from the changes it's a
little less overbearing so that for that
remaining objection from the first time
we heard it to stand up i think that
would be a bit hard to argue i think
because it technically meets
our standards in terms of parking i
think that seems reasonable i'm a bit
wary about the tandem parking and the um
how tight the turning area looks but i
guess if highways and everybody else is
happy then
that's not really a leg to stand on
either so at the moment i'm stopping
short of second in council dixon but
uh yeah i'm
heavily minded to go with the officer's
recommendation as well
thank you anyone else want to speak in
the debate at this point councillor
curtis then fleming
yes i
don't really have any strong objections
um i think as the officer said it would
be
if if something could be put in to
encourage an increased number of ecvps i
would certainly welcome that
counselor
um
i think they've done what they can to to
improve the overlooking
situation here it's never going to be a
pretty building in a pretty location
um
but uh hopefully that the extra parking
would improve the off street that
obviously improved the off-speed parking
that may well make the actual parking
much better on the street as well so
i'd be looking to follow my colleagues
on the other side of the room
council adam you want to come back in
i'll second the proposal
you beat me to it i think i'll add my
thoughts at this point i understand what
council mills means here i i don't love
this application i'm clear on that one
but we've seen it come back in several
iterations now and the applicant have
tried has tried to address some of the
concerns we had we've seen a reduction
in the roof lights
and i do think this is an improvement to
parking although i do sympathize with
the parish accounts if you've got a road
that's really chock-a-block
you always feel loathe to add anything
else to that although i i do feel i
think there's a possibility that this
will actually ease the situation
although i accept that you might not
agree um so there we are so if we've got
an application we've got the proposal
that's been proposed and seconded
council cuts i i know you said about the
ev vehicles i'm not sure what else we
can add uh paul on that one are you
happy that you can
flesh that out because we're not going
to change there i compare the notes on
that but i'm sure you know the way the
committee's looking at this so it's okay
right let's go to the vote if
everybody's happy with that then so the
uh proposition is to grant
uh all those in favor please show
two three four five six two
against
okay well in that case the committee
therefore resolves to grant application
reference twenty one slash
zero one five one eight slash ful
we go to our next application this
evening which is item seven
and on page 35 of your agendas
excuse me um okay this is application
reference then uh
21
0 one seven seven four slash f u l and
it's site address one and two chester's
green cottage
uh a number of changes uh which i don't
propose to go through if that's okay
i'll leave that to presenting officer
victoria campton over to you
perfect thank you chair and good evening
so this application at numbers one and
two chester's green cottage concerns a
pair of semi-detached properties
planning permission is sought for joint
two-story part single-story rear
extension
on each house as well as other
alterations
the application sites are identified by
the black dot on the map
to the north of morton bagger
so the site is outlined with a red line
on the current site collide
number one lies to the north whereas
number two lies the south
in terms of constraints the property
occupies a rural position within the
greenbelt pardon special landscape area
and is close to ancient woodland
the green hash line to the north shows a
public right-of-way
but this slide shows the existing
elevations when viewed from the front
number one is on the left whilst number
two is on the right and you can see they
both have a symmetrical visual
appearance as you can see on the rear
elevation both houses have a rear
outhouse projection which is considered
to be original
turning to the development the main part
of this proposal is for a two-story rear
extension which would span the entire
width of the buildings this projection
at first floor level would have a depth
of approximately 2.5 meters and the
design would include four engables which
would mirror each property
there'd also be a single-story extension
on each each house which would measure a
further four meters in length both of
the single story elements would have a
dual pitch roof
and would be a similar form
the proposed windows would be similar in
appearance to the existing and the
materials would also be to match
at ground floor level the roof of the
rear conservator
number two would be replaced whilst an
open plan living area would be created
on number one at first full level the
accommodation would not add any new
bedrooms but the development is to
increase the size of the bedrooms on
both properties
the first floor extension to the front
of number one but also add an ensuite
photos one two and three are taken from
the street outside the site number four
is a satellite image to show the wider
context and surrounding countryside
evidently the properties are situated
with a rural setting with no nearby
neighbours and occupy a prominent
position within the landscape
photos one and two side show the side
and rear of number one and similarly the
side and rear of number two is shown on
photos number three and four
as referred to in the delegated report
the shed and garage including the
volumetric calculation on number one are
included in
photo number three
so in terms of updates a member's site
visit was conducted earlier today as as
listed on the update sheet
on the whole officers are recommending
refusal of this application for the
reasons outlined in the delegated report
which concludes my presentation thank
you
thank you victoria okay we go to our
first speaker um councillor paul harvey
please yes paul harvey
welcome counsellor
take a seat do
okay
so you also you've been watching the
proceedings so you also have three
minutes to speak um if you'd remain
seated at the end of your time and uh
answer any questions the committee may
have for you
i'll let you say it
you're all set yeah over to you okay
thank you um i think this is a
relatively unusual application because
you've got a joint application between
neighbours who've worked hard and worked
together to
try and come up with a scheme to
improve and extend to modern standards
some relatively modest
cottages
and i think they had to be commended for
for that if nothing else and i think we
we should we can probably agree that the
the scheme before us
is an improvement on
on what's there now um
the the issue is as has been agreed with
the officer the the scale of the um
development in comparison to what's
there now in the old days there was a 30
rule i seem to recall which is no longer
applicable and we're we're left to take
a view as to
um
the scale but um
and the the according to the office's
view is that the scale is having an
effect on the green belt an adverse
effect on the green belt
but i would stress from the parish
cancer's point of view these are very
small cottages um they do need uh to be
improved really and they will inevitably
be improvements made to them over the
coming years to to meet modern standards
um and we feel that these are relatively
small extensions
in context of what's there now which
will have no effect on the green belt
and so we're happy to give you our
support and ask that um the committee
take a view on the same vein
thank you
thank you council harvey any questions
for the parish council councillor dixon
this may be a question that you can know
the answer to if you don't i will be
asking the applicant in any case um do
you know how old these properties are
um i don't specifically but i would i
would say they're late 19th century
thank you any further questions
no in that case council harvey could i
ask you to wipe down the desk thank you
very much your eyes already excellent
and we can move to our next speaker the
applicant jan
welcome
that's excellent welcome
right see sat there patiently so how you
you know the routine by now hopefully so
you have three minutes i'll give you a
warning at 30 seconds if you need it and
remain seated for any questions at the
end
that case over to you
good evening councillors
we the current owners of number two
chester's green cottage together with
our adjoining neighbours have lately
submitted a joint planning application
as advised by the case officer in order
to extend both properties to the rear in
line with each other and to the first
floor very simply we wish to enlarge our
second bedroom which barely accommodates
a double bed
to a more usable size
and enable number one to have an
upstairs bathroom along with slightly
larger bedrooms for their two children
there will be no increase in footprint
to number two and both cottages will
remain two and three bedroom homes
respectively
this joint application follows a lengthy
process whereby two previous
applications have been made and later
withdrawn on the advice of the case
officer
it is now the recommendation that this
application be refused
essentially on the grounds that
increasing the size of one bedroom at
number two exceeds the 30 permissible
extension volume to homes within the
greenbelt
thereby causing harm
we understand that this is because our
timber tool shed
stands within 5 meters of the house and
is being included within the volume
calculation
with regard to policy cs10 paragraph 419
we believe this 30 figure the case
officer is using should not be used as a
benchmark of determining what is or is
not small scale
instead the benchmarks as noted within
the policy are openness to the greenbelt
and prevention of urban sprawl each case
should be decided on its own merits and
we believe a 30 increase in volume to a
small house is still a small house
in correspondence the case officer has
stated that more harm would be caused to
the green belt by moving the
aforementioned tool shed despite the
fact that we could potentially create a
separate outbuilding and incongruous
side extension under our permitted
development
the current proposals have then been
rejected despite being barely visible
from the roadside and in addition to our
office up in addition to our offer to
waive any further permitted development
rights
determining whether very special
circumstances exist depends on the
balance between planning factors and it
falls to the lpa to decide if they do
exist and if they outweigh harms the
greenbelt
the case officer has admitted that
relocating this tool shed elsewhere on
the site will cause more harm
therefore in our opinion special
circumstances do exist and there is
there is potential to cause more harm to
the greenbelt than this scheme actually
proposes
in conclusion we have worked hard with
our neighbours to devise a scheme that
gives both households what they need
be that sufficient space for a young
family to thrive or the ability to adapt
to the changing needs of two aging
occupiers for many years to come
this level of cooperation trust and
foresight between neighbours is rare and
should be commended not punished
for both sides it is our forever home in
which we have invested many thousands of
pounds and will continue to do so
it is most definitely not
and will never be
profit making development project rather
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to upgrade both these period cottages in
line with current standards whilst
keeping their character symmetry and
outward appearance thank you
thank you
okay do we have any questions counselor
dickson
thank you relax
uh they age of the properties
thank you do you know how um i think the
officers indicated that the garage of
number two yours uh was not built at the
same time now you know when that garage
may have been we believe it was around
1980
about 1980
and the tool shed that you referred to
um obviously there's an equestrian use
within
the
area yes yeah what's the tool shed used
for the tool shed is for as
as says for tools um it's a fairly
sizable property with a large garden
we've got a lot of equipment in there
such as
garden equipment
chairs seating um
just the general tools that you would
expect with a sizeable house a flexible
car sufficient thank you
okay any other questions
no
in that case thank you very much for
your time this evening if you'd wipe
down the desk for me thank you
right in that case we'll move to our
our speaker on this item
that's the hendrich seraphim board
member
thank you i think you know the routine
five minutes
well this will be fairly short but
condensed
um
i've visited this site on numerous
occasions i've studied it i've been
round it i've been inside
and i'm supporting this joint
application for modern day living
number one
has only
one bedroom one bathroom number two has
one small bedroom
to the rear and they just want to extend
that to make it more reasonable size
the case officer seems not to have much
of a problem with number one but number
two with volume
she has taken the garage on the shed
which you've heard about in the volume
calculations
um i did ask her for the calculations on
the shed and she couldn't give it so
i've measured it and calculated at
16.2 square meters or 34 cubic meters
if you want to take that off
um
the shed was replaced by the present
occupier because there was a
dilapidated greenhouse on the site
so all they've done is taken the old
greenhouse down and put the shed in
there when they purchased the property
if it comes to the case that they have
to move the shed fair enough but
we don't have a set um
volume policy at the moment these days
the case officer points to one similar
view taken in recent dismissed
discussion
at 57 green lines studly
but fails to mention
this was a four bedroom detached house
so i wouldn't say it was anything
similar at all
um the one i would say was similar
and which was granted in mapleberry
green not so long ago
was for an extension of one bedroom and
a bathroom over an existing garage
on a two-bedroom semi-detached property
to give the family modern day living as
they had two children
is my view this application does not in
any way harm the openness of the green
belt
it doesn't increase the footprint of the
buildings
it would improve the aesthetics
from the rear view of the property
blending in with the existing and i
would say within a few years you
wouldn't even know anything had been
done
both of the property owners
want to remain living in the cottages
they don't want to have to move
unfortunately might have to consider
moving
as the properties will be not be
suitable in the future for them to live
in because how small they are
we as a council
should be supporting
this type of application to help for
modern day living
i have witnessed
the anxiety of people
when they face this type of application
and it can be life-changing for them
so i urge commission members to support
this application and granted
thank you thank you councillor any
questions for our member councillor
dixon
thank you chairman peter i
mentioned on number property one that
they've only got one bathroom is that on
the ground floor or on the first floor
because i think we heard from uh jonath
that they hadn't got
they were hoping to get a bathroom on
the first floor
it's on the ground floor
thank you
okay any other questions
that case counselor thank you gotta wait
thank you don't forget to wipe down the
table for me thank you right okay uh
points of clarification do we have any
questions anybody maybe at all
councillor curtis and captain mills
thank you um yes can you i wonder if we
could just clarify
that
um
does that no permission wouldn't be
required to relocate the tool shed were
the owners
willing to
wishing to do that
there are committee development rights
under class safe for outbuildings um
usually would require a lawful
development certificate to confirm its
lawfulness
um
we don't have the evidence in place to
to demonstrate that permitted
development rights are intact but there
are there are permitted development
rights for outbuilding so it may be
possible but i
couldn't confirm
fine thank you
okay council mills yes thank you um
it is
the concern of you is the effect on the
green belt in the main isn't it that's
what we're looking at the effect it has
on the green belt that's all i need to
know thank you
any other questions
question yeah go for it council's
plumbing
um the the tool shed what's the
construction of the toolshed what you
know what's it made of
there you go it's a it's a wooden a
wooden shed i can get a photo of it on
on um
so you can just visualize it better but
we would consider it to be a building
just bear with me
and it's that one there
right let's go to the debate then
council dixon just beat you to it
councilman sorry
thank you chairman uh looking at uh
cs16 i think is it
green belt oh cs-10 cs10
uh the greenberry is all about the
protection
of uh the openness of the green belt and
trying to prevent uh as it were
connorabations and villages and towns
and all that moving together
essentially that's obviously not at risk
here
and when i actually look at some of the
wording here on page 72
um extensions should not cause material
i.e
significant harm
i was on the site visit today and the
proposed rear extension
will not cause to my mind
significant harm to the openness of the
greenbelt
i am minded that it's not long ago
that a member within my ward
was able to persuade this committee
there's an upstairs bathroom with a
modern convenience they only had a
ground floor bathroom in that particular
property and members were minded to
fully support that on a unanimous basis
um i think the provision on in number
one of an upstairs bathroom makes
admirable sense
i was asking about the tools shed as to
whether or not it was actually domestic
because obviously extensions of a
domestic nature are counted and i think
i have the answer is it was domestic
because it was more associated with
garden than the equestrian use within
that area but that said
uh we're still left with a situation
whereby the overall proposal here is for
a 68 increase in volume
on property number two
with only 40 on property number one
but equally well
uh the policy also proposes that it is
good
to actually
improve the aesthetics of properties
and certainly the proposal that we
actually have here
a similar mirror image across the back
of these two properties i think is
better than just it being on the one
and
if i actually look at
the officer's report as well
there's a lovely phrase in here
which
um i think it was overall the proposal
would harmonize with the character and
the local distinctiveness of the host
dwelling the street scene and the wider
local area
i fully agree it does harmonize the
proposal will harmonize with the
character and distinctiveness and i
would propose that we grant this
application
and accept that
this would be an improvement to the
property and it would not have a
detrimental impact
of any significant harm to the openness
of the greenbelt
thank you councilor dixon councilman
thanks mr chairman yes i'm i i couldn't
go on the side visit today but i did
go at the weekend or last sunday uh to
look at it i'm very pretty conscious
they are too um i can understand the um
the applicants not wanting to move from
there and uh in indeed uh
like council dixon um
i could only see it as an improvement to
be honest mr chairman and it's
i can't see the significant harm to to
the actual green belt so
i did you put a proposal in he did oh
well the second that then mr chairman i
was taking that thank you
councillor jennings
obviously um
with this and if we decide that it's
small scale
um we're not determined by the 30
percent but obviously these are
um they used to be but
we now do it on a case-by-case basis
so if we do decide that this is small
scale we don't have to take in
to consideration special circumstances
so i understand
that's correct yes that's correct
okay you very much
councillor fleming thank you
um
i think i'd like to side with my
colleagues on this because um apart from
the fact the footprint is not changing
um the view from the front of the
property isn't changing
um
that
modern living is a big thing and farmers
cottages were tiny things so so from
that perspective i would support what my
colleagues are saying on this
council jennings
just one other thing i think it's very
important to point out
that
all of these should be considered on a
case-by-case basis if this was a
particularly large
or medium-sized building in the
greenbelt
um i certainly wouldn't be supporting it
but due to the scale of the size of
these houses
it's to me
i don't
i you could argue that it's a small
scale development because they're
small-scale houses but
thank you council adam
thanks chair
i agree with what's been said entirely
and to my mind the inclusion at least of
the tool shed
albeit technically correct by all means
is
to me if they took the shed down which
is mentioned in the in the
offices report resubmitted the same
plans we might be having not even a
committee with it and then they could
put their shed back up i think we're
it's a little bit um
it's a judgment call entirely but
absolutely agree with what everyone else
has said so far thank you okay i'll add
my thoughts i think i agree with the
majority of everything's been said so
far tonight i feel sorry for officers
when you get these ones because they're
really difficult they really are you
must hate having these applications land
on your desk because it's such a finely
balanced one
people so caged in by the planning
policy on this one it's really difficult
so
excellent report and consider why you've
come down on that side but i agree with
what's been said tonight by everybody
else so council jennings come in i just
wanted to add in that uh i thought the
report was absolutely excellent and
there's a very professional showing
round today around the property i just
wanted to make that note of that
tough job um right okay um we've got a
proposition and a second or two grant
this one uh we should talk about
conditions shouldn't we so if i go to
richard maybe standard set of conditions
i'm guessing
talk us through yeah i can give you the
headlines um for the conditions what
they would be if you're happy to agree
the detailed wording to officers uh
delegated authority
the conditions i would recommend would
be a standard time limit number one
number two in accordance with the
approved plans
number three materials to match the
existing
number four in accordance with the
submitted climate change measures and
that would apply to both
properties
number five is a little bit more complex
because the applications come in as a
pair
if either were built on its own it would
cause
harm to the other neighbor so they both
have to be built together so we've
crafted what we think is a condition
that will cover that
and i'm going to read that out in full
to get delegated sorry to get approval
from committee and it would really no
part of either extension hereby
permitted she'll be occupied until the
adjoining first floor element of the
neighbouring rear extension approved
under this planning permission has been
substantially completed in accordance
with the details shown on the plan and
then it's the plans approved as part of
this
and that's to ensure that the interest
of the joint immunity remains
um
so that's that's a one-off condition
really that would be all the conditions
that we'd recommend and then there would
be four notes
uh standard mppf
bats nesting birds
and a note about the extent of the
lawful cartilage which is a matter
raised in the report
but those would be the conditions and
notes we recommend
i mean i think we've probably really
outlined reasons for going against
officers recommendation but if you want
me to just try and summarize and they
might i might come back to council dixon
from health as well i think what i've
heard then is on the whole committee uh
viewed this to be a small scale
uh application small-scale development
to the uh to the house and the overall
we think the benefits of modern living
to the applicants uh outweighs any
impact to the green belt and we see no
significant impact to the setting or
space of green belt are you happy with
that
uh yeah obviously um
obviously i disagree with that the
planning judgment but most importantly i
think you followed the right process
there you've looked at
the scale of it included at small scale
you've looked at the impact on the
openness and concluded that there's no
significant harm since councillor dixon
said that
and now that you've done that you don't
need very special circumstances you've
concluded it caused the green belt
policy and there's no other matter at
issue so i'm comfortable with those
reasons lovely um i'll go to council
dixon you happen happy with the summing
up of everything there and the
conditions
get some mills
fantastic let's go to the vote then uh
the proposition then is to grant this
application call those in favor please
show
one two three four five six seven that's
unanimous joe that's unanimous therefore
the committee therefore resolves to
grant application 21.01774
ful thank you
right
our last application this evening uh we
can go to now i think this is item eight
on the agenda
okay right
okay this is application slightly
different everyone tonight so public
footpath public public footpath
diversion sm51 part of napton on the
hill
it's very complicated i'm going to hand
this over to presenting officer mason
ash
thank you mesa over to you thank you
i'll probably get tongue twisted as well
chap just to confirm that the matter has
come to committee because we have an
objection to a footpath order which has
not been withdrawn and under our
constitution
uh the planning committee must assess
whether it should be referred to the
secretary of state for a decision
uh note uh there are further updates
from the ejector objector on the update
sheet
and i will answer any points on that
correspondence if the member's wish
the report has set out the details of
the history to this matter
at times quite complex so i've no need
to go through that again but we'll take
questions from the members if anything
needs clarifying in the report
basically the main issue is convenience
or inconvenience
as part of the highway test to the
general public
another main point is about intrusion
there are other matters which i've set
out in the highway test in the report
so basically we'll be looking at the
inconvenience or convenience space
between points a
and point i
i've showed you the um the order plan
but i'll show the um the 2016 permission
which caused all this issue
that was the outline
in red and then basically the cross
hatched was where the extension went
uh unfortunately the extension was built
over
the uh sm51 which is where my cursor is
there
so basically uh we
followed um the proposal which comes
through the driveway and through into
the field
uh basically all the uh pre-order uh
consultations we're happy with that that
doesn't mean it's it's been put out to
the general public yet
um but all the pre order consultants
were happy with it
so basically we made the order and that
is the order plan
so basically what i'm going to show you
now
some videos and apologies to my lack of
technical ability on video recording
i've tried my best
so basically where i'm going to start
i'm going to start just up in chapel
lane where h is and first i'm going to
show you
the proposed
um footpath basically to point
e
so i to e
so this is on chapel lane
as you'll note it's a very quiet street
and i've just stopped it there
because
you'll see in a minute when you actually
come out of the driveway in a car
there's an incline which you have to
come up and then you have to stop there
to see what traffic comes
is coming up the road
so basically uh
because of the way the nature of the
road
there are the safety issues which have
been discussed
uh in my view
it's all quite safe
so this is the
footway from chapel lane down to the
high street that's the first garage then
basically we go
into
the proposed area this is the driveway
of viewlands
and basically carry on
you can just see the incline there
and you have to come out on there slow
there's no way you can come out of this
driveway quick
and we get to that point there and
basically this is where the gate there
was a gate there it's now being removed
because of um this issue has been taken
so long
and then basically you'll go through the
gate and into the open field and there's
a style down this is the bungalow on
halcombe lane and there's a style there
basically just straight to the field
down to the style
all right the next one this is the
existing
so basically i'm
just stop that for a minute
okay so i'm back on point h again
you can see the slowness of the um at
the road because that delivery lorry was
taking its time to go down there it's a
very narrow road now this is the footway
so that's what's proposed down the
driveway
and now we go down the footway
from chapel lane
down to the entrance of
the old bakery this is 20 meters
i will get there don't worry
so this is the existing let's see by the
slabs it's an uneven surface it's also
very narrow
but carry on up the scaffolding
shouldn't be there so just ignore that
then there are steps up the footpath
there's a gate there
to basically uh for privacy purposes
and this is into the garden of the old
bakery oh i'll shut the gate first
that bench shouldn't be there but
people need to go around
and then we are
still in the old bakery garden and these
are steps down to the old bakery house
at the back
so there are some
safety issues there
and then we go through this gate
and we go into viewlands now vielens is
the one who submitted the application
for the extension in the first place and
also
permissions for the driveway and garden
which was subsequent and why this was
delayed chair for over a year because we
had to wait for the applications to come
in
so we continue
this is existing
get to about that
box to my left hand side
and then basically the footpath veered
off
basically through that window
so it goes through there
so at the moment we've got a temporary
access to allow people the general
public to actually
still keep on actually accessing the
original
or sort of the existing
footpaths
those are the steps down to the
extension
and then we get to the gate
and that leads to the same field
and that again is the bungalow and the
style is down there
so basically
i would refer members to page 54 and 55
that's set out the um the tests there
are five tests
based on the
um
8.3 down to 8.7
the actual legislation tests are in
italics and then i've put my account and
council's comments below that
the probably the most important ones are
uh 8.3 and 8.4
basically that's
confirms uh about the openness of the
new footpath
um so it's not restricted like the so
it's convenient to all walkers
but also takes it away uh entirely from
the old bakery property it doesn't take
it entirely away from viewlands
but it comes into the driveway so
basically it's not intrusive members of
the public don't feel uncomfortable by
using the actual uh footpath
um
also the second point is and i'll read
it out to you uh basically
and the legislation says basically
further that the powerful way will not
be substantially less convenient to the
public inconsequence of the diversion
and my comments were the approximate
route is so the new route is
approximately 20 meters to the north of
the existing route access at the old
bakery and therefore is not considered
to be substantially less convenient for
walkers whichever way you access the
route
and i would also add that the county
council have also confirmed that
this footpath public footpath is
actually closer to sm50 which is is up
there
basically chair um
the recommendation is to refer this to
the secretary of state um unless the
objector
in them
in the meantime wishes to withdraw
his objection but that's the
recommendation sir i'm i'm quite happy
to take any questions thank you well do
you have any questions counselor dickson
thank you chairman me sir
as far as the objectives are concerned
is there a measure of reasonableness
just as a matter of interest as much as
anything or can people you know object
provided they can find
a
a
minute aspect to do so
yes
i mean he's uh but um the objectives
point is that this was a major diversion
my
opinion on this is it's not a major
diversion 20 meters is not major if it
was probably the
coming out of the butts to the north
then to me that would be a major
diversion but it's it's not it's it's
basically still on the footway
between chapel and high street but yes
they can
object to anything um but if you decide
to refer to the secretary of state then
he's basically he's got to argue that to
the secretary of state that this is a
major diversion
okay
anything else
no
debate
council jennings i think council mills
apologies no
um i don't consider this 20 meter
diversion to be inconvenient to walkers
i'd like to therefore propose that we
refer the order to the secretary of
state
thank you
that's the mills
thanks for chairman yes i agree um
when i did visit the site and it took a
long time to find this this footpath and
while i did find it
gosh it is a nightmare no it really is a
you probably break your leg anyway but
this is not a big
diversion and i
could go with um i can't say office
rocket recommendation but um
i can't see a problem with it thank you
had a formal second yes a formal say
thank you council mills maybe i want to
speak
okay let's go to the boat um all those
in favor of the uh recommendation to
refer this
i didn't even get to finish it uh thank
you please
thank you that's your name
that's right okay thank you
in that case the committee resolves to
refer this public footpath diversion
sm51 to the secretary of state as
outlined in the recommendation there is
no further urgent business this evening
therefore the meeting is now closed
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
no definitely not